tout autre d'un tout autre sujet c'est
cette affaire vincent lambert alors
c'est maintenant peut-être dans un autre
centre de soins que l'homme de 42 ans
tétraplégique ans va être transféré
il est actuellement toujours à l'hôpital
de reims les soins et l'alimentation et
l'hydratation repris ce matin après la
décision de la cour d'appel de paris
mais ce coup de théâtre juridique d'hier
est loin de tout régler l'un des 20
films is de l'agriculture alors ça peut
surprendre quand parle on a choisi cet
extrait parce que justement il parle
delà de cette loi qui selon lui une
règle pas tout ce que l'on voit là c'est
la faillite du système
la fête de la loi claisse leonetti et le
fait que n'arrive pas à aller au bout de
ces sujets c'est vraiment quelque chose
de profond qui touche aux au plus
profond de soi même qui touche à apt
pour certains à la religion pour
d'autres à des à des convictions c'est
ça qui est terrible
moi je pense à ce pauvre ce pauvre homme
qui est tétraplégique et une famille qui
se déchire
c'est à ça qu'il faut penser c'est pour
ça que on voit bien que c'est pas une
loi qui règle forcément le problème du
hamel vous êtes quand même le jurer sur
ce plateau
la loi nous dit le ministre elle ne
règle pas tout et pourtant hier on a
fait alors c'était pas la loi leonetti
en tant que tel c'était une décision de
droit qui a fait autorité
c'est un des deux problèmes que me
posent cette question très lourde
c'est la contradiction de décision en
droit entre le conseil d'état et la cour
d'appel de paris pense qu'il ya une
sorte de compétition un peu malsaine
entre entre ces juridictions qui est lié
au fait qu'en france vous avez dualité
de juridiction donc vous avez pas sa
seule et unique ami seulement
administratif et judiciaire
c'est quand même un problème quand bons
d'un côté la plus au deuxième la seconde
plus haute la cour d'appel de paille
disent des choses contraires sur le même
sujet c'est un peu ennuyeux
la deuxième chose c'est que je trouve ça
terrible l'ampleur de la médiatisation
autour de cette histoire et
qui est une histoire très vite mais
personnel d'une famille et donc je sape
gêne que qu'on se déchire là dessus
qu'on s'engueule là dessus que qu'on
commente sa consoeur exceet dans un cas
et dans l'autre on commet parfois comme
si c'était un match de foot enfin il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui qui me heurte
je trouve ça devrait rester de mai en
revanche les citoyens et tous ceux qui
nous écoutent devrait en tirer une leçon
très clair c'est qu'il est quelles que
soient les limites ou pas de la loi
léonetti claisse leonetti il existe les
directives anticipées
cr qui consiste à écrire à l'avance ce
qu'on veut qu'il soit fait de nous s'il
nous arrive des choses
médicalement tragique ou très lourde et
c'est très très très facile vous allez
sur internet vous tapez directives
anticipées il ya même des modèles qui
vous semblait et rien de plus simple il
ya aujourd'hui une toute petite minorité
je crois de france est enfin sous les
20% que comme ça qu'ils ont fait et au
moins ça éviterait des déchirures paille
quoi entendre une mère et une épouse
s'affronter avec les annonces à des
sujets mon avis on ne vide pas de son
sens la sphère de directives anticipées
une des questions c'est qui peut parler
au nom de du la personne en fin de vie
ou du malade en l'occurrence la loi
léonetti même ne s'appliquerait pas
puisqu'elle s'applique aux personnes en
fin de vie et il n'est pas au sens
physique en fin de vie d'autres la
question c'est qu'est le tuteur légal et
et là c'est vrai parce que c'est la
femme est ce que c'est les parents est
ce que c'est les enfants cible c'est la
femme qui a été elle a été mise en scène
a été désigné mais leurs racines du
conflit familial
elle est en fait elle est là et donc
même la une
enfin une loi etc je suis passé un
moment dans une famille les parents
veulent pas s'entendre avec le benfica
donc vous avez l'idée que la loi peut
pas tout régler mais c'est évident
talent ça c'est pas tout régler et en
l'occurrence la loi léonetti dire
qu'elle n'est qu'elle n'a pas marché je
prête nom elle s'applique pas ce cas là
à la voile lundi ne s'applique pas à ça
la loi léonetti c'est pour quand
quelqu'un est en train de mourir de
l'accompagner pour pas qu'ils souffrent
pendant qu'ils meurent mais là il ne
meurt pas c'est ça la difficulté c'est
l'âme ça pose un problème de la loi
c'est à dire que très franchement entre
être atteint d'une maladie très grave et
se trouvait dans un état terrible du
fait de cette maladie ou avoir un
accident très grave et se trouvait en
état végétatif la question de savoir si
on veut continuer à vivre ou pas elle se
pose dans les deux cas ne se pose pas
que dans le premier cas
valérie toranian on peut pas le préjugé
c'est très difficile mais c'est la loi
pourrait prévoir des cas parce que
complexe lorsqu'on du gaz 1500 personnes
par dont justin chiffres puisque il ya
1700 personnes qui sont en état dans le
pot si relationnel comme on dit alors
avec des cas très divers bien évidemment
mais dans un état comme ça ma végétatif
mais qui ne sont pas en fin de vie je
pense que la loi leonetti au départ
c'était une loi qui était assez habile
assez fine est assez complexe et elle
était parfaite
justement pour des cas de figure
j'allais dire un cas de figure un peu
l'idéal c'est que le cadre qui
s'appliquait donc c'est à la fin de vie
une famille qui n'est qu'il ne serait
pas déchirer d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler que c'est dans
la majorité des cas ce qui est bien et
ce qui se passe mais les gens sont
d'accord la famille et à ses amis maires
dans la discussion avec lui
en tout cas le cas de vincent lambert a
poussé justement voilà la logique
jusqu'à jeu
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout et là on voit
bien que non seulement elle est
impuissante elle s'applique pas elle est
sujette à interprétation et chacun y lit
il entend dans la loi ce qu'il veut donc
le fait de dire qu'au delà d'une
obstination déraisonnable etc les les
traitements peuvent être arrêtés peuvent
ça veut dire quoi ça me va dire doivent
donc peuvent wii ou ne peuvent pas enfin
vous voyez tout est sujet à part au
trafic de 6,2 voilà mêmes traitements
c'est parce que c'est ainsi que des
soins donc non seulement il faut pouvoir
donner des instructions de son vivant
mais si on les donne pas il faut aussi
peut-être pouvoir désigner
si vous arrive quelque chose dans la vie
qui votre interlocuteur auprès de
l'équipe médicale quoi on peut dire que
c'est ma mère c'est mon père c'est mon
frère c'est ma soeur c'est mon mari mais
je pense qu'il ya aussi parce qu'il ya
des gens qui savent pas forcément et
puis c'est pas évident de décider fin je
pense que dès qu'on touche à des
questions aussi humaine et sensible de
vie et de mort
voilà et la loi suffit pas il ya aussi
amendé à conditions l'article de la mort
alexis nous draper pas quelqu'un afin
d'animer mais en même temps comme le
disait olivier ça fait onze ans qu'il
est dans cet état je voi quand je vois
la photo de
vincent lambert qu'elle regarde ses yeux
voilà vidéo d'ailleurs passé la vidéo
mais la vie la vidéo qui a été assez je
connais mon idée à cette affaire que
l'autre d'ong dont on a pensé à venir
parler dans les médias qui est celle de
l'ancien footballeur international jean
pierre adams qui lui à domicile les
épaules et son épouse ses enfants ses
petits enfants 10 et une manif est très
sensiblement sa joie son bonheur quand
on vient le voir au delà auprès de lui
et je vis cette vie familiale compliquée
mais on la vit avec lui il n'est pas
question où ils disent ça dure une façon
d'appuyer plus de variantes c'est heidi
qui décide
j'ai lu deux témoignages totalement le
témoignage de quelqu'un qui disait qu'
il y avait un vrai regard et qui
pleurait et j'en ai lu un autre qui
disait que absolument pas quand on est
c'est un truc
ce ne sont pas des larmes de tristesse
et deux absents posée donc on ne sait
rien on envoya car on voit on va pas se
prononcer en son nom mais c'est parce
qu'elles savaient pas vu non mais c'est
pour ça que des larmes c'est difficile à
dire mais moi j'ai vu ce matin sont deux
vidéos qui sont sur twitter tout on peut
voir je parle pas des larmes parce que
leur vrai qu'on a on peut projeter ses
émotions dans un regard mais on le voit
qu'ils regardent qui déglutit quand on
le nourrit qui suit des yeux et qui
ferait des grognements quand on lui
parle donc je sais que je veux dire je
sais pas ce qu'il ressent 40 et ce qui
est sûr c'est quand on voit ce garçon là
où on voit bien que c'est un être humain
qui vivent ya pas c'est pas du tout et
légumes secs on nous dit c'est un légume
non c'est pas légumes du tout alors
l'autre question c'est est-ce qui
s'ouvre est ce que sa vie pour la peine
d'être vécue mais quand même c'est qu'on
n'en sait rien le sentiment qui donne
mais je je je veux pas ce jeu mais on a
besoin que c'était une sorte de bébé
c'est à dire que sk avait veut pas
s'exprimer mais il a quand même des
émotions
il ne souffre pas d'être un bébé soit en
tout cas on voit
projet de beaucoup je prends pèsent en
tout cas ce qui est clair c'est qu'enfin
c'est que quand on dit dans un coma
profond ce nom en 2008 hâtif
il est pas semer végétatif on voit on le
voit sur les images n'est pas du tout
végétatif il parle pas il est mobile
mais mais les médias quand même
plusieurs médecins qui sont prononcés
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un peu un
signe des temps de remise en cause alors
à tort ou à raison de deux la science en
disant bon les médecins puis dire ça
mais nous on ressent ce si on pense que
ça je crois que soit de l'agriculteur à
raison de la loi peut pas tout la
science non plus on a tous dit que au
fond ce qu'elle prouve cette personne
lambert on en sérieux un journal qui est
pas si mauvais qu'ils s'appellent le
figaro son éditorial
son éditorialiste d'hier dit j'ai donc
il ya doute etienne de montety notre ami
etienne il ya un doute et en je parle
sous le contrôle du juriste olivier en
droit le doute doit profiter à l'accusé
les choses laissant le vivre les soldes
ce que c'est c'est quand même lui donner
la mort moi je peux je regarde ceux des
ses yeux laquelle la photo que vous avez
produit tout à l'heure je ne veux pas qu
est mort parce que c'est de dire parce
que je sais très bien
comme un espèce de nihilisme scientiste
un peu prométhéen verte il nous a menés
on sait bien parce que les mêmes veulent
aussi fabrice crise dans cette critique
dont vous parlez de la science ont dit
oui à tous les médecins les médecins les
paquets médecin mais enfin sans la
médecine sans la science est sûre le
progrès ça fait longtemps qu'il serait
mort
c'est pas parce qu'ils font ça contre le
progrès mais sans le projet il y aurait
plus de 20 ans lambert depuis longtemps
quelques réponses de nos en tout cas
commentaires de nos internautes déjà la
question vous demander selon vous la loi
peut-elle répondre à l' affaire vincent
lambert vous êtes 62% deux tiers d'entre
vous pensent que non un peu moins
veulent pas su toujours nous dit
pourquoi plusieurs juges avec les mêmes
rapports médicaux donne des résultats
différents servia savez ce que vous
expliquez aux débuts olivier d'un côté
le conseil d'état appelé hier la cour
d'appel de paris
en fait parce que j'avais qui considère
que le l'avis du comité sur le handicap
des nations unies comme on l'a ratifié
dois tu vois ça pour la noue alors que
d'autres voudraient tant qu'entraîneur
qu'il n'est pas contraignant donc c'est
un désaccord c'est l'âme successeur mais
sur des cas comme ça ils vont éviter
d'être en désaccord quand ils seront d
accord sur l'interprétation d'un bail
rural pour savoir à quoi c'est pas
dramatique quand ils sont en désaccord
sur une affaire aux fondements les gens
se tendaient sont pas en tout cas pas
explicitement désaccord sur le fait même
un sur le sujet le désaccord porte sur
la valeur de norme par rapport à un
traité c'est pas
c'est pas sûr avec comme conséquence
avec mes mais l'entraîneur ne porte pas
sur le cas sur la valeur de l'art c'est
souvent comme ça le droit voilà nous dit
et ça sera peut-être la conclusion cette
affaire aurait dû rester dans la famille
humble direct sign on et directives
anticipées et alexis je compte sur vous
en ce qui me concerne aucun doute il
prenait la [ __ ] sur la police voulait
faire vivre nos médailles en aucun cas
ce serait vraiment tellement méchant
bout
elle aura encore un petit peu d'énergie
pour parler de la sphère web
alors c'est bien une guerre froide te
croyais nature conférence tous les
matins et huawei on me reproche
waouh c'est bien donc d'une guerre
froide technologique qui est lancée
entre les états unis et la chine les
etats unis qui ont interdit aux
entreprises américaines à commencer par
google de vendre leurs produits au china
huawei
ce matin on apprenait que les américains
donné un sursis 90 jours avant
d'appliquer ces sanctions
mais compte tenu des enjeux commerciaux
mais également technologique
on comprend que c'est grave même si on
n'a peut-être pas tous les tenants et
les aboutissants cette méthode de trump
du coup de poing sur la table hier une
réunion finalement ça paye
j'aborde la méthode trump il l'a dit
dans son livre célébrissime l'art du
deal le la méthode trump s'est pas tant
que c'est un protectionnisme c'est pas
un vrai protectionnistes qui n'a pas
d'abord aux 32 je pense de penser avec
une production profonde que ça en
revanche le digne c'est ce que c'est un
deal c'est ce que c'est et je pense que
tout ce qu'il fait il le fait en pensant
j'avance j'avance mais mais mais
il argumente j'avance les atouts bien
timide j'ai impressionne mais on
commence à les navettes au fil de ces
toujours et basse assez je commençais
bas il risque de se passer ça aussi
parce que si à un moment donné
la sanction la pénalité pour les
entreprises américaines s'avèrent trop
lourde si ça devient contreproductif il
suffisamment il n'y a pas d'état d'âme
il changera mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il veut c'est pas c'est pas un
c'est quelqu'un qui veut absolument
protéger et se mettre dans un bras de
fer écrasé la chine
il a aussi besoin de la chine et la
chine a là des moyens